it's bitterly cold and damp and these
flimsy tents offer very little
protection this camp on the edge of
Calais is mainly refugees from Sudan
just 100 or so of the estimated 4
million people who fled the horrors of
Civil War in that country is it that
desperate that you would put your life
on the line that you would risk your
life but I don't have a life you know I
don't have a life I don't have a life in
my country Muhammad arrived here just a
few days earlier
it's very risky
would you take a boat if you had the
opportunity yes of course I would
the numbers using small boats to cross
the narrow but deadly stretch of water
between France and England have grown
exponentially from just a few hundred in
2018 to nearly 46 000 in 2022
in global terms those numbers are small
but to the UK's right-wing government
the boats have become a totemic issue we
will pass new laws to stop small boats
making sure that if you come to this
country illegally you are detained and
swiftly removed
since 2021 sunax government has promised
140 million dollars to the French for
extra police patrols and improved
security the UK also plans to deport
migrants to Rwanda although none have
actually gone yet and yet The Crossings
continue and so do the efforts of the
Charities trying to offer support they
are being treated like criminals when
actually they are people fleeing
conflicts and persecution they're people
who are looking for safety who are
looking for friendship and a safe
passage a safe illegal route a
humanitarian Visa similar to the
Ukrainian steam would be a perfect
solution to end a lot of policy issues
the French police go through the motions
every two days they break up the camps
but with nowhere else to go the refugees
simply return immediately afterwards
Louis Witter has spent the last six
years photographing the situation in
Calais the strategy is absurd it's
because every 48 Hours people are
expelled from their camps there are no
Solutions offered to them there are no
centers open to welcome them for example
they're just told you have to leave
these places the British prime minister
has pledged to stop the boats the
question is how and the related question
is why do you treat it as a criminal
problem to be tackled or as a
humanitarian crisis to be solved either
way tens of millions of dollars have
been spent until the tide has not been
turned Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Calais